Film Courage: Let’s talk about inconsistency
for creatives, versus the people that are
so on the nose and so concise, but maybe they
have lost some of the creative flair? I happen
to see a lot of people who are inconsistent
and are incredibly creative and actually have
brilliant ideas, they just don’t follow-up
on them. And on the flipside, the ones who
actually do follow-up…sometimes the creativity
or flair still needs to be fleshed out. How
do you nurture both types?
Lee Jessup: Well you really have to look at
writing as a job rather than a muse, right?
Larry Karaszewski and Scott Alexander talk
about how they wrote The People and O. J.
And Larry F. and a whole bunch of biopics
and bio dramas. And they talk about this is
a job and we go into work even when we don’t
feel it. And some days the writing is great
and some days it is horrible but it’s the
work.
Sometimes you have to write through a lot
of horrible pages to get to some good pages.
I’m a big believer in that. Sometimes you
have to try something different. So it’s
staying agile and open to the different ways
to access creativity. Sometimes it’s rejecting
creativity and just going for inspiration
and through inspiration getting back to creativity.
But you have to accept that what works on
one script will likely not work on the next.
And so you always, always, always have new
tricks to try in your writing, new ways to
access the work, new methodology to follow,
new things that will inspire you.
You know, that if nothing else, you go and
do something for fun because fun begets motivation.
So whether your fun is dancing or hiking or
jogging on the beach or whatever it is, you
usually come back pumped up and excited.
That said, creativity is tough to always channel
so a lot of my writers rely on meditation,
on regular workouts, on tracking systems to
set their expectations for what they are going
to create and when.
A lot of self-journals, a lot of goals and
targeting so that at some point your system
begins to understand that you have to show
up whether you feel like it or not.
Film Courage: What are those tracking systems?
That’s really interesting.
Lee Jessup: There is something called SELF
Journal that a lot of my client’s use that
is a planner, a task driven planner with short-term
goals and long-term goals. A lot of writers
rely on systems like Pomodoro that requires
25-minute sessions. So it really varies and
depends on the writer. But every writer finds
their path. So some writers write for page
count. Some writers write for hour count.
You have to find what is your comfortable
space. To write three pages at a time or six
pages at a time or three hours at a time.
What can you meet and what can you meet consistently?
Because it’s kind of like going to the gym.
The first few days are going to be really,
really hard. Especially when you haven’t
been in a little while. On day 13, 14, 15
you are going to hit your stride and if you
keep going then you are going to be fine.
And it’s the same with writing. You just
have to keep doing it in order to get comfortable
with it. The beginning is always going to
feel rusty and clunky. By the end, you are
going to be hitting your stride.